you're the I sort of know you sir fine
you know cuz a friend and an associate
was long now for a long time and your
collaboration with him has been amazing
in terms of the product but your
collaborative generally you seem very
comfortable working with other artists
and and out of the interplay getting
some extra thing is that yeah say more
about how that works for you
for me when a collaboration works and it
it can work fairly often mm-hmm pretty
good percentage of times you get
something extra you get something that
neither of the collaborators would have
done on their own and and both of them
or however many there are realize oh
this is greater than the sum of its
parts or it's a third thing that has
come into existence that is neither of
us but it's something of something else
it doesn't always work I mean there's
some times when it just doesn't but when
it does that's really exciting I've
heard other musicians say kind of that
they hate the idea of collaborations
really so some it feels to them that it
is watering down the authenticity of the
of the author it's a compromise of some
sort which which it is you're inevitably
compromising but if you get something
greater they'll to me that's worth it